et la vie elle allait aux yeux bleus
mais hélas c'est anne holmes qui cette
année là je sors
[Applaudissements]
mais ça
à
marie
si je laisse les rênes du portail
[Applaudissements]
toc toc toc et la base et justine juste
une photo de toi juste une photo de toi
[Applaudissements]
il avait reçu du courrier aujourd'hui
dans tout pourquoi non mes partenaires
sont geneviève jeune des filles
geneviève je te bouscule
[Rires]
je vais jouer
[Musique]
aujourd'hui
oui qui est là edmond edmond qui est non
contrôlé
[Applaudissements]
elle me contrôle vite me mets pas si
elle me frôlent aux non je ne réponds
répondrait pour plus de toi / - inter
milan sur la dance show à merde quand un
kart a souri
[Applaudissements]
y a des
c'est celle à la chose
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est hélas hélas elle a les yeux bleu
marine et reid
enzo enzo enzo toutes belles belles
belles comme eux
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]